you do now well i'm basically
disappointed in the
results um and you know i take
full responsibility for the results and
i will take full responsibility
for fixing things we have changed
as a party but we haven't set out a
strong enough case
to the country very often we've been
talking to ourselves instead of to the
country
and we've lost the trust of working
people particularly in places like
hartlepool
i intend to do whatever is necessary
to fix that what will you do because
some people in your party are going to
say you need to move
more towards the jeremy corbyn agenda
others
away from it this is not a question of
left
or right it's a question of whether
we're facing
the country we have changed as a party
but we've not made a strong enough case
to the country
we've lost that connection that trust
and i intend to rebuild that and do
whatever is necessary
to rebuild that trust but what does
change mean
in say policy terms it means stopping as
a party
quarreling amongst ourselves looking
internally
and facing the country and setting out
that bold
vision for a better britain and changing
the things
that need changing what is that is the
change that i will bring about
lem mccluskey united general secretary
says people don't know what you stand
for what is that vision
our vision is of a country that ends the
injustice and quality that millions of
people face